bueno leer una novela
es un acto amatorio que nos enseña a
querer mejor y es también un acto
egoísta que nos enseña también a tener
conversaciones espléndidas con nosotros
mismos
carlos fuentes
carlos fuentes yo creo que nadie pudo
haber expresado mejor lo que sí es leer
que carlos fuentes él lo toma en dos
puntos el primero que es un acto egoísta
entendemos ese momento cuando estamos
solos y leemos yo lo entiendo como el
que que estamos leyendo que estamos
llenando en nuestro cerebro de
información de conocimientos aprender
cómo se ven las cosas desde los ojos de
otras personas que viven en otras
latitudes o que incluso vivieron en
otros periodos de la historia y está el
acto amatorio que nos enseña que eres
mejor yo lo entiendo como el para que
eso que nos mantienen motivados a seguir
leyendo a seguir conociendo y también
digo que es aquello que nos lleva a
llenar el corazón vamos a poner un
ejemplo y más acá a ver piensen en ese
libro que los obligaron a leer
qué tal álgebra de baldor
ese libro es el que ahora el para que
para que lo leí
si me responden que es porque el maestro
los obligó es el es el para qué vamos a
hacer un poquito más dramáticos el para
que sería bueno yo permití que me
obligarán a leer un libro porque era un
requisito para poder aprobar la materia
si yo no probaba esa materia no podía
recibirme del bachillerato si no me
recibía del bachillerato no podía
alcanzar una carrera universitaria que
me permitiera defenderme en la vida pero
sobre todo si no pasaba esa materia
podría poner triste a mi mamá cierto
entonces ese es un para que un caso
cercano a mí porque creen que yo he
leído libros infantiles los últimos
cinco años de mi vida casi seis
así porque me gustan porque están
bonitos se relaciona con el trabajo no
el para qué va más allá en casa tengo un
pequeño niño comelibros que yo quiero
quiero lograr acercarme a él a través de
las letras quiero que la lectura sea una
experiencia que es una alternativa para
él entonces lo que hago es que leo
libros que me gustan pero también un
montón de libros infantiles que estaré
dispuesto a compartir con él luego
quiero que piense también en la
experiencia de lectura ahora imaginen
imaginen ese libro que conecto con
ustedes que un día terminaron de leerlo
este es el momento en que lo terminaron
de leer que sienten es el libro ya no es
cualquier libro es el libro conecto con
ustedes si llego por su cabeza y ahora
desborda por el corazón creo emociones
emociones que están que él siente
desbordando entonces tenemos la
necesidad de compartirla este la gente
del mundo lo va a saber que ese libro es
especial para mí y podría llegar a ser
especial para ellos
bueno cuál es la forma de transmitirlo
una forma sería escribiendo otra forma
sería platicar bueno eso lo llamamos una
experiencia de lectura una lectura
significativa porque significa algo para
mí un año me sucedió que encontré
autores locales principalmente potosinos
algunos nacionales y para mí era un boom
era descubrir nuevos mundos que yo no
conocía y que quería expresar con los
demás para entonces ya participaba yo
activamente con un grupo de lectores en
la universidad donde laboraba ahí
hacíamos un círculo tradicional que es
esto
coordinábamos una lectura por mes y
hacíamos sesiones de seguimiento con los
alumnos y los maestros para dentro de
algunas oportunidades se están
proyectando películas que se
relacionaban con los libros era una
actividad que nos funcionaba bien que
nos gustaba mucho pero nosotros algunos
de los alumnos y maestros sentíamos que
queríamos más queríamos llegar a más
personas
queríamos mayor libertad porque bien de
cuenta es un formato educativo nos
permite tener una guía así pero nos
limita la participación activa de todos
los miembros entonces nosotros queríamos
hacer
queríamos participar más queríamos
alejarnos de ese formato nos acercamos a
nuevos grupos de lectura y notamos que
las estructuras eran muy rígidas qué
pasó después decidimos elegir hacer un
propio círculo que tuviera las
características ideales para nosotros
que eran primero tenía que ser gratuito
queríamos que estuviera centrado en el
lector y sus experiencias de lectura
queríamos también que fuera respetuoso
con la libertad del lector
no queríamos que nos dijeran que leer
cuánto tardan los dos leer y dónde
tenemos de leer
queríamos que eso fuera nuestra libertad
queríamos también un espacio que fuera
accesible céntrico y bueno todo esto le
fue dando forma a un grupo que le
llamamos letras vivas bueno y quienes
estábamos incluidos les digo los mismos
maestros que estaba en el grupo original
los mismos alumnos que estaba en el
grupo original más la gente que sigue
incorporando llegaba gente a la librería
y nos veía platicando parecía como un
grupo de amigos platicando sobre el tema
cualquiera pero siempre estábamos con el
tema central de los libros entonces en
una sesión teníamos la visión del número
de personas que participaban si iban 15
electores teníamos la visión de 15
libros diferentes y participamos por
turnos a qué se parece en esa
participación bueno se parecería más o
menos como aquel fenómeno cuando ustedes
van con su libro bajo el brazo lo llevan
para todas partes y alguien curioso les
pregunta de qué trata tu libro bueno si
ustedes tienen la apertura de compartir
lo que dirán a continuación esa
experiencia de lectura a pues se trata
de esta cuestión lo escribió tal autor
me gusta o no me gusta vale entonces es
hacemos en nuestras vidas pero por
turnos y con el tiempo decidimos poner
únicamente dos reglas es decir cualquier
libertad requiere un límite nuestras dos
reglas eran reglas de convivencia
primera regla no podíamos dejar de
respetar a la persona por lo que dijera
por lo que él leyera o por como luciera
la gente merece un respeto por ser
persona esa regla de convivencia es para
y la segunda regla de cómo era la de no
contar spoilers elementos del final del
libro o claves para la trama entonces
eso no nos va a arruinar la experiencia
de lectura si alguien el libro que yo le
platiqué le interesa va a poder
acercarse es el libro leerlo sin miedo a
que yo le haya ruido arruinado la
experiencia bueno ahora a qué peligros
no se fue bueno aquí le teníamos miedo
como letras vivas cuando iniciamos un
proyecto de lectura quiero pensar que
cualquier persona que inicie un proyecto
de lectura le tiene miedo a lo mismo
las estadísticas de lectura del país
inés y dice en el módulo de lectura del
año pasado 2018 con la actualización de
febrero de este año que leemos los
mexicanos mayores de 18 años
indistintamente del sexo y el district a
mente del formato del libro digital o
impreso un promedio de 42 por cada 100
personas si habían leído algo en el
transcurso de los últimos 12 meses un
año y esas 42 personas incluidas en
entre estos 100 habían leído un promedio
de 3.3 libros durante los últimos 12
meses ese número es mucho o es poco
vamos a analizar si de esos tres puntos
tres libros
el porcentaje de uno
libros académicos o formativos
el otro uno por el otro el otro de los
tres sería superación personal o
cuestiones de religión y únicamente uno
de este 3.3 se refiere a literatura
entendamos novela poesía cuento ensayo
de acuerdo entonces es muy poquito
hagamos un cálculo rápido si aquí somos
unas 250 personas y por cada 100
personas 42 están leyendo libros y 242
personas leyeron 3.3 tendríamos un
aproximado díganme si me equivoco de 320
y 340 libros leídos más o menos ahora si
le quitamos los educativos y los
religiosos pensando en que tal vez la
persona fue obligado a leerlos porque
recuerden que de 18 años o más todas son
universitarios algunos están trabajando
entonces tan capacitarse tienen que leer
libros técnicos nos estaríamos quedando
únicamente con 110 libros de literatura
si lo ponemos en un librero serían
apenas dos charolas
es muy poco pensando que son muchísimos
tendríamos que pensar en subir ese
índice de lectura pero pues también
necesitaríamos pensar en hacerlo de modo
colaborativo bien a propósito de la
colaboración letras vivas descubrió que
era muy interesante la charla entre
lectores pero queríamos algo más
obviamente la innovación sería algo que
nos caracterizaba como grupo entonces
con el tiempo empezamos en redes
sociales facebook es una plataforma que
nos sirve inclusive en este momento para
hacer las citas para documentar todo lo
que hacemos twitter nos sirve para
acercarnos a muchos escritores muchos
escritores sigue en twitter youtube nos
permitió acercarnos a los escritores de
una manera diferente podíamos
entrevistarnos y acercarlos a las a los
suscriptores que no tenían mucho apoyo
editorial a un medio conocido como
youtube donde muchos lectores también
están inversos ahora bien dentro de la
sesión de letras vivas pusimos una
sección que le llamamos salud
el escritor invitado que es justamente
eso dentro de nuestra sesión del círculo
de lectura que era como nosotros la
queríamos dejábamos un tiempo para que
un escritor principalmente local
presentará su trabajo presentará su obra
y nos dijera qué es lo que sabe hacer
porque a veces no leemos a los locales
porque no los conocemos bueno entonces
con el tiempo vimos que podíamos también
invitar a otras personas personas por
ejemplo como filósofos gestores
culturales programas de lectura
diferentes al abrir nuestras puertas eso
provocó que otros grupos de lectura
instituciones educativas instituciones
culturales
nos abrían las puertas a nosotros eso
nos generó un nuevo compromiso y un
nuevo reto llegó un momento en que como
grupo de lectores estábamos en las
universidades dando pláticas
conferencias talleres iniciando nuevos
grupos de lectura que implementarían el
modelo de interacción que nosotros
manejábamos y estaba funcionando nos
invitaron de otros estados y siempre
nuestro compromiso fue con la calidad de
expresar lo mejor de nosotros cuando
estuvimos en palacio municipal nos
abrieron una experiencia que eran
charlas entre lectores nosotros
desarrollamos temas de literatura desde
nuestra experiencia y nos turnábamos las
participaciones para que la gente
tuviera una frescura que solo puede
provocarse de ver diferentes caras
hablando de diferentes temas en un mismo
espacio bueno entonces que en que cree
david que creo yo bueno yo creo que una
herramienta poderosa para acercar los
libros a las personas van a ser las
propias personas que están leyendo vamos
a hacer un acto como
como como inclusivo invitar a las
personas a leer desde el gusto
hamas desde la imposición porque nos va
a pasar como le pasó al libro de baldor
que cuando ya no tuvimos la necesidad de
leerlo lo guardamos en lo más rotundo
del librero lo regalamos lo tiramos o lo
quemamos entonces bueno yo los invito a
que lean a que compartan a que no les dé
miedo a veces tenemos la sensación de
que no somos lo suficientemente buenos
para opinar sobre un libro créanme en lo
que nosotros sentimos vale más que lo
que un experto a veces a veces por
supuesto a veces que lo que un experto
puede opinar por qué porque cuando
pasamos a otro el y entendemos que no
sólo es lo que dice el libro lo que esté
escrito sino que va más allá porque las
personas que escriben libros sienten
piensan vivir una situación tienen una
motivación que los llevó a escribir si
podemos entender qué es lo que nos llevó
a escribir podríamos decir que estamos
entendiendo a otra persona y al entender
a otra persona
también nos estaríamos entendiendo mejor
a nosotros mismos y quiero pensar que es
algo algo bastante
optimista que si entendemos a los demás
ya nosotros mismos podemos tener un
mundo mejor y ya bueno eso era todo y
sobre todo decía para invitar a la
lectura debemos ser muy respetuosos de
verdad este cuando hablemos de libros
debemos considerar que la persona tal
vez no ha leído los mismos libros que
nosotros tal vez no entendió lo mismo
que nosotros pero si queremos que esa
persona lea lo comparta e invito a otras
personas seamos muy respetuosos no los
hagamos menos nadie sabe menos todos
tenemos diferentes habilidades
diferentes experiencias que nos van a
hacer enriquecer como grupo si entonces
un grupo de lectura nos va a ayudar a
entender mejor nos va a ayudar
tienes mejor muchas gracias
[Aplausos]